françois hollande go I think it's
a good chair but right now
it's not too much the case it's a bit
difficult for France from below
it was just to tell you that you
we have all very disappointed the
room has changed although you have
do it's marriage for everyone then
today that's me I voted for
you
there were plenty of things that were
promised I am very disappointed I remain
still left but I'm waiting
really a radical change is not
very interesting not my hair rather
comic as president me it will be a
question about selective immigration
that is to say like in canada a
easing a little bit for that
avoid that everyone goes back to
borders something more
square gée also highlights that you
personal business are quite
outrageous she looks at you
you alone and not spread out in
newspapers only have your friendships
besides all the media beast and you
here he just has us
we all voted for him, hoping
that there are plenty of things that went
change made us hope at home
to do nothing he was what makes
our country but not ours
I love you people are stupid
understand nothing i love you i repeat
ok I'm looking there I think that in
does he have nothing to do in power
and that we beat nicolas sarkozy and go
definitely replace it at next
presidential elections
we are a student you see our
the only wait is to unite studies and
from sincere strangers
we can see that today in France
can not afford to succeed
believe charles language please
wake up
so françois lamy is the brilliant
wake up and sharp better like that
and affirm yourself and then do the
courage Mr. President of Courage
and I hope you are going to change
a lot of things you still have very
very little time so I really hope
that you will change things for
young people in France because it's not
obvious
wood said